how you feeling this morning John
pretty good dan how you doing buddy I'm
doing okay don't okay when you're on 18
and all of a sudden it sinks in what do
you thinking when you finally won for
the first time since o4i it's just like
you just never know if it's ever going
to happen again you know what I mean
it's just your fight you fight you fight
you keep trying and trying and it just
doesn't seem to happen and then when it
finally does it's just it's just a big
relief you know that uh I got the monkey
off my back I'm a champ Easter I got to
win and hopefully hopefully I can do it
again you know it's it's not easy to win
on any tour uh-huh what was missing why
me I think I can speak for a lot of guys
those guys have been on that door for
seven eight nine years that haven't won
yet that have come so close and you know
it's just it's just not easy to win you
know some some weeks you play really
really great golf and you think you've
won enough and somebody else should 64
on you you know it's just it's just not
easy to win all we can do is keep trying
to help to try and keep getting in
contention to give ourselves a chance
did you forget what it felt like to win
you know what next when I go to
Birmingham next week I already forget
about it because now it starts all over
again
how soaked were you with after that win
because that looked like they were
pouring everything but pond water on you
Michael Allen that's the bond they were
great they got my eyes a little bit but
you know what it was it was worth it to
me I mean it's just cool that you know
this tour it's such a close knit all the
guys are so cool there's such great
players and you know we think
competitive all our lives we played a
lot of us have played the tour together
and everybody roots for everybody out
here it's really something that you
don't see often in a sport that you know
we are competitors but we also most of
us are all friends and we all get along
we go out to dinner we have a couple
drinks together and in everybody's room
for everybody out here
I'm talking to John Daly he had his
first win since 2004 the bein sperrit e
invitational i saw this quote help me
with this 2004 so the last time you won
was 2004 there was the target world
challenge and you were in the prolam and
you're in the clubhouse having some
beers telling stories and then Tiger
walks into the room what happens after
that oh I just tried to get him to sit
down have a beer with us he is a piece I
guess he went out and hit about three
hours three or four hours you sprocket
sitting me and my guys were sitting
there drinking beer having a good time
and he comes in with his workout cousin
Tiger sit down and have a beer or
something with us and he says if I had
your challenge I'd be doing the same
thing I said come on man you wouldn't
everything I'm not winning anything come
on do you think that you guys if you
were a little closer to Tiger in how he
approached it and he was a little more
like you that it would have helped you
guys well I don't know Tiger is so
focused I mean he's you know he's kind
of like very a very field natural golfer
with the mentality of a Nick Faldo or a
Jack Nicklaus you know I more of a fuzzy
Deller Arnold Palmer Lee Trevino type
guy I'm loose and fancy free I'm not
going to go beat a hundred million balls
I'm I'm going to play a lot of golf and
practice when I play I like to I like to
play and hit three or four golf shots on
the hole when I play I don't like this
I'm not a ranger at and which is you
know I just can't sit out there and hit
balls in a field that long I don't know
how these guys do it but he knows to
each his own and whatever makes you feel
comfortable whatever you think and play
your best golf that's what we do I don't
know if you're the right person to
answer this but I'll ask it anyway
do you have more natural talent than
Tiger I don't know I think I think we're
really close on that but I think his
seal around the Greens when he was
winning all those tournaments was a lot
better than anybody I think even at a
point where you can almost say was
Nicholas's and you know you watch guys
like Cory McIlroy and Jason Day and now
Dustin Johnson commits himself to his
wedge game you can compare that to just
you know some of the greats ever but no
I don't think I think Tiger was always 1
1 2 2 3 4 steps ahead of me in this game
I think his focus of mentality is
probably one of the strongest I've ever
seen in a golfer really close to what
Nicholas did and you know I was more of
a like I said I was more of a Palmer
fuzzy lee trevino I just and even
landing Watkins I'm a streaky player I'm
not a great putter every day and luckily
I was a great putter for three days but
you which is due for your confidence
level I don't know where your confidence
level was on the Champions Tour but what
does this mean I just you know I'm gonna
play in a future events this year the
British Open a PGA and you always have
confidence after you win and I got some
great golf courses coming up I love
Birmingham where we're going next week
you know I think I had some like 19
birdies and four Eagles their last year
and finished 7-under par which means I
made a lot of big numbers but we just
kind of go with the flow just go to the
next week and you know you just keep
trying and trying to get in contention
and you know the good thing about the
Senior Tour is there's less guys your
chances are always better when you have
less guys but you know these guys are
incredibly their short games are
incredible at our age it's amazing how
good these guys are short games off
where all your trophies do you have them
all ah well I've got my two majors on
the bus and the rest the rest room in my
home and Dardanelle somewhere I gotta
look for him okay we were curious if we
could get a donation to my man cave what
would you like I like the pants from
yesterday's win you know what Dan for
you I'm going to sign them and I'm going
to give you the shirt and the pants
awesome I'm gonna I'm going to have a
John Daly mannequin in here and I'm just
gonna I'm going to dress up the John
Daly
Anakin well you're gonna have to get a
big bag make up a lot of room by the way
the next time I see it don't greet me
the way you did at the Hootie and the
Blowfish concert
you don't like me kissing you on the
mouth no no not anymore John not anymore
now that you have a you know steady
girlfriend no no I don't know if we made
her jealous but that was I I tried to
turn away my son goes did he just kiss
you on the mouth I said yeah I think so
yep you did that's saying that's
brotherly love yes the others more
importantly congratulations we
appreciate you joining us and good luck
as you go to Birmingham thanks so much
we always love you I love your show
brother thank you John that's John Daly
big win yesterday yes I'm off the side
of the stage of the hooting the Blowfish
they have a golf tournament Monday after
the Masters I'm standing there with my
son John walks over my son goes as John
Daly I said yeah he'll be over so then
John's like survey in the whole
situation there he sees a couple people
then all of a sudden sees me and he
starts to come over and I when a John I
put my hand out boom right in for the
kiss my dad goes there my son goes does
he do that all the time down I go no I
don't think so and I hope you doesn't do
it again yeah took one for the team
there
thank you John the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience